asset-backed securities or abs is a
familiar phrase but what exactly does it
mean imagine a business owner gets a
bank loaned by some real estate if he
can't pay back the loan the bank has a
problem so how does the lender deal with
that risk one option the lender bundles
together these loans into larger
products and sells them off to investors
then it's an asset-backed security or a
BS it sounds like a win-win solution on
the bank side when many smaller loans
are bundled together they're easier to
sell and for buyers asset-backed
securities can be an attractive
investment investors snap them up they
seemed like a safe and lucrative deal
but it turned out that many a BS ha's
were built on a shaky foundation and
were far riskier than they seem
after the global financial crisis the
credit bubble collapsed many of the loan
packages went into default today the ABS
model has fallen into disrepute now the
European Central Bank or ECB wants to
step in the ECB will purchase asset
backed securities that it has deemed
safe from banks the banks will get a
cash infusion in turn they can issue
loans to companies and private
individuals
the ECB hopes that will spur investment
and give the economy a boost but there's
a risk if the debtors default again the
ECB will be liable for the loans and in
the end it's the taxpayers who could be
left holding the bag